[Music]
[Patricia F. Brennan, PhD] Good
afternoon. I'm Patti Brennan,
the director of the National Library of
Medicine. And today I'm excited to have you
join me in a conversation with one of our most
distinguished investigators, Dr. Eugene Koonin.
Today, our conversation is going to
travel through a wide range of ideas from
the communication of cells across time to the
comparison of viruses and other cellular life.
Dr. Koonin's thinking about how
various life forms evolve over time
has been instrumental in driving many
discoveries in contemporary biology.
Did you start out experimentally or
computationally to study viruses,
or did they become a serviceable good
model for you to study evolution?
[Eugene Koonin, PhD] I started my career as
an experimental virologist trying to study
RNA viruses, maybe without outstanding success.  But
soon after, these RNA viruses have indeed
become an excellent, probably best at the time,
playground for the emerging discipline
of comparative genomics. Because,
for the simple reasons that, at the time, these were the
complete genomes that could could be sequenced.
[Brennan] What got you into the computational
tools for understanding viruses?
[Koonin] The first complete genomes of any
biological entities have started to accumulate.
And these biological entities, at the
time, were exclusively small viruses.
And these represented both an
opportunity and a challenge.
An opportunity because these were complete
genomes to compare and try to understand.
A challenge because, without special
effort, without developing dedicated
computational approaches, very little
could be understand from those sequences.
I don't think that the community, at the time,
was entirely prepared for that situation,
but it was rectified fairly soon, and I am I'm
very pleased to have played some role in that.
[Brennan] Well, we've talked before about
your interest in genomic evolution and
that the the manner in which organisms
change over time. And I'd like you to
talk a little bit about that now, and if
you could specifically talk a little about
the challenge of understanding
conservation versus mutation.
[Koonin] All genomes that exists, exist
on our planet, result from
billions and millions of years of evolution. To put it
very simply, when we compare genomes of
either closely related, or
distantly related organisms,
we delineate conserved and less conserved
variable paths. And what we can see is that the
highly conserved part are involved in functions
that are essential for the organism's survival.
Conversely, the parts that are variable
contain genes that are involved in interactions
between organisms and in interactions
between organisms and the environment.
[Brennan] So when you speak about conserved, this
is not only sections of the gene that appear over
generations of the organism, but also that
appear commonly across groups of organisms.
[Koonin] It's useful to note that, by now it's a
firmly established plain fact, that all cellular
organisms - I'm not talking about viruses - all
cellular organisms that exist on this planet originate
from a single common ancestor, a so-called LUCA.
Last Universal Cellular Ancestor that existed
about 4 billion years ago.
Just a little bit less maybe.
This was probably the most brilliant hypothesis
in the history of science proposed
by none other than Charles Darwin.
The entire history of life, an unimaginably
long history of life on our planet,
spanning about 4 billion years, is permeated
by persisting evolutionary relationships.
There is, to be even a little more specific,
there is about a hundred of genes that are
shared by all cellular organisms, from
mammals to plants to amoeba to bacteria.
[Brennan] I'm going to turn our
attention to your experiences here
at the National Library of Medicine.
And you've been here 30 years?
[Koonin] Actually even a
little over a little longer.
[Brennan] A little longer.
[Koonin] Exact. Exactly 31 now.
[Brennan] 31 years. And you have had an
illustrious career, many trainees and many,
many, many papers. Wonder if you can talk a
little bit about how the National Library of
Medicine's resources have shaped your work
and how you have helped shape our resources.
[Koonin] It has been an incredibly welcoming
and fertile environment for the evolution of
my own scientific career, my my research group.
And combines very good resources with pretty much
unlimited academic freedom. Which sounds almost
too good to be true, but nevertheless is true.
[Brennan] You spoke at one time of the
importance of the BLAST algorithm for
your work and then further modifications
of that. Could you speak a little bit
about the analytical tools that you
use and what we provide for that?
[Koonin] BLAST is a centerpiece of
computational biology and genomics.
A completely indispensable tool
which quickly compares sequences
of nucleic acids and proteins. And their are.
At the time of it's development, which
incidentally coincided with my arrival here.
This was by far superior by any other
available methods. It was actually
the only real game in town. The only
way to efficiently compare the gene
and genomic sequences. Very timely development.
I don't think that any other
tool or method developed here really compares with
BLAST in importance. It should be noted however,
that there is substantial competition in the world
now that hopefully advances the field as a whole.
[Brennan] I'd like you to reflect for a moment on
the contribution that you delight in
the most in your scientific career.
[Koonin] Perhaps I should mention the
CRISPR system. And what CRISPR is,
is widely known because this is known as the new
methodology for genome engineering and editing,
which is far more efficient and
fast than previously available ones.
But, in in biology itself, this is
something also of great interest
because CRISPR is an adaptive immunity
system in in microbes in in bacteria.
And before this was discovered, it was not even,
no one even suspected that adaptive immunity,
fundamentally similar to our
own, existed in bacteria.
And with my colleagues, through
comparative genomics approaches as usual,
we have been instrumental in the discovery
and further characterization of this system.
Many labs contributed, but I think I
think our contribution is noticeable.
[Brennan] I want to close by congratulating
you on your election to the National Academy
of Medicine this year. I was quite proud to have
another member of our NLM staff become recognized
so widely for critical contributions,
and I congratulate you personally.
[Koonin] Thank you so much. It's
a certain certainly a great honor.
[Music]
[Music fades to Silence]